statistical tables for the normal
distribution and I want to call your
mind back to what we've been doing just
the last couple of days this is the
normal distribution in the bell curve
right we're pretty familiar with it now
it is a phenomenally useful model
because it sort of represents the
probability density function of pretty
much everything bless you pretty much
everything that is the result of a lot
of Independence processes so we talked
about all these examples before things
like Heights temperatures wherever
you're measuring a bunch of things and
there's going to be minor variations
maybe just because of you know genetics
or because of just like errors in
measurement you get the normal
distribution so it is really really
useful okay we then said once you get
this guy if you want to work out
probabilities underneath this you have
to integrate right like that's that's
where we that's how we use the
probability density function areas under
curves give us probability and then we
landed on this problem right we looked
at this function and we're like gross
don't want to integrate it so I told you
right the outset there were three ways
to solve this problem and they all
started with T the first one was so so
in fact it's in some ways the order
doesn't matter but the first one I said
was technology okay and I will use that
as my reminder that if you go and have a
look at the topic 14-page where you got
the booklet that we've been using in
this topic hopefully you've at least
looked at it once but maybe it looks
different from the last time you saw it
these are all the kinds of things which
I've been referring to during our
lessons grammar steady but haven't had
the time necessarily to teach in class
in particular I just have a look at this
one right down the bottom this is as
Alicia said this is using technology to
solve that integral so go ahead have a
look at that we also said we did this
yesterday we did by hand there was
another t method that we could use what
was that called trapezoidal well thank
you very much so we had to call their
minds back to integral calculus and that
way of approximating areas under curves
and that leads us to the third and final
one which is statistical tables now
basically the reason why we have these
is the following
for trapezoidal rule and for technology
if you're on the normal distribution
you're always dealing with this same
shape you're always dealing with this
same function so you're like you're
gonna write like 50 integrals in a row
and they're all that function people
like oh we need to integrate this over
and over again I keep on using these
same numbers
why don't I tabulate these numbers then
I can work these out without having you
know all the fancy software and that
kind of thing that I would need to
evaluate the integral directly now is
still approximate because these tables
as you're going to see don't have
infinite you know numbers of values in
them but they are close enough for us to
use so at this point what I want you to
do is to open up the booklet and the
page number is page 50 and you're going
to see a table here it says table 1 area
under standard normal density okay so I
hope you can see it right there I'll
make it a little bit bigger for you okay
so what are we looking at what do all
these numbers mean essentially if you
know a particular z-score you can work
out a probability that goes with that
like a cumulative distribution function
will tell you so let's pick a z-score
for example this is page 50 page 50 okay
you can see down the left-hand column
this is almost like a stem-and-leaf plot
but in two dimensions so on the
left-hand column just just over here
right you might want to say oh I want to
have a z-score of like 1.6 see that 1.6
there and I can get more accuracy by
saying 1.6 what give me a number guys
give me another decimal place one point
six four was the clearest one that I had
so I say if I'm on the one point six row
which is across here right all of these
values correspond to different decimal
places after the point six right so
Alicia I think you said 0.64 so you can
see up the top there it's point zero
four so now what I do is I'll use
another color now I go down to this
point zero four column and you can see
there's a number that intersects between
the two of them zero point four four
nine five do you see that
so what does that mean on your graph of
a normal distribution and if you haven't
got one just draw a rough one for
yourself right now just like I have okay
what this point four four nine five
actually represents is like the title
says it's an area underneath this curve
but what area is it no one look at
cumulative distribution functions right
the whole cumulative idea is you start
from whatever your lowest score is and
then you count up to whatever score you
happen to be interested in does that
make sense that's the whole accumulating
idea okay so I said that these numbers
are like a cumulative distribution
function they start from zero and they
count up to whatever Zed score you just
provided so we said a z-score of oops
sorry one point six four I think was the
number that we came up with okay now if
I go to my normal distribution they say
I should be able to fit three standard
deviations away from the mean so I'm
going to go one two three one two three
in the opposite direction so these will
be Z 1 2 and 3 and Z negative 1 negative
2 negative 3 as you go to the left okay
so where's one point six four one point
six four if this is one and two is
between one and two right so I'm just
going to draw a line in there let's pick
a easier c-cup yeah a bit past halfway
I'm gonna call it around there okay so
the number that we just found by reading
off the table zero point four four nine
five like I said you start from zero and
then you go forward to whatever Zed
score you just says so so that would be
this this is the area that I'm after
this makes sense so I just I just picked
out a number one point see I asked you
guys to give me another actually and
that was the number that we together
ended up with okay I could pick any
other number on here there's a lot of
different numbers that I could choose
from but I just wanted one to start with
okay now the one difference I said it's
like a cumulative distribution function
but it's not exactly the same because a
cumulative distribution function starts
from the very beginning if this is a
normal distribution where zero I mean
you can see it's not at the beginning
where is it
it sits in the middle at the main @mu
right so that's slightly different and
it's why if you go to the top left of I
hope have you got the table in front of
you now because mine's a bit small I
know you'll mean to read it yourself
have a look at the very first value you
can see in the top left-hand corner
it's a Zed score of zero so you like oh
if I start at zero which is in the
middle and then I go to zero you can see
that there is a no area underneath that
curve right don't go to it just yet just
think about it for a second as you put
in larger and larger values of Z 1 2 3
what value should I be tending towards
what's the biggest value I'm going to
get now think very carefully remember
you can see it on this graph I start
from the middle right so if you start
from the middle and you start going to
the right you're gonna go to zero point
five do you agree it's only half of it
right which is why if you have a look at
the entire table right have a look at
the bottom right-hand corner you see
that some what's that correspond to a
Zed score of three point nine nine do
you see that so three point nine nine
that's a very high Zed score what is the
area under the curve it's zero point
four nine nine nine
there are obviously more nines that go
after that but there's a limit to the
amount of information we can fit on the
table does that make sense you see how
we read this question okay now it's up
it's worth mentioning this is actually
I'm glad you picked this up you might
notice on this page if you're on the
correct page it's this table one at the
top right there is actually in fact
there are many different kinds of tables
and the way you use it will depends on
what kind of table it is this lesson
we're really just going to use table one
I think it's the most useful one okay so
now that you basically know how to use
this thing let's let's do some examples
and let's explore okay so maybe you want
to jot this down what we going to do
first up is to use this table to try and
evaluate this probability okay if you're
on a normal distribution and you want to
know the probability of you know getting
a Zed score if I randomly select someone
in this group
I want to know the probability of
getting a Zed score between naught and
1.23 again I just picked that that value
out at random okay so how I use the
table to help me here
what's the heading today Sarang make the
heading and I'll answer the question for
you okay how we gonna find this well I
wanna start from zero and that's exactly
what this table does right and then I
got want to go up to one point two three
one point two three so one point two I'm
gonna have to read on the left-hand
column can you see that one point two
can you see where it is I'm spotting it
about I'm gonna get rid of actually all
of this other stuff I spot it one point
two as there so that's the row that I'm
interested in are you following so far
don't point to it yep
okay so if I wanted one point two eight
you can see this table right this table
it goes to two decimal places if you
include the rows and the columns that's
why I'm going up to the columns now you
can see if I wanted one point two eight
I'd go over to I don't need to go a bit
further there's the point zero eight
yeah okay so you got to look closely I
wanted one point two three didn't I
okay so hopefully you can read up to the
correct column and there's the number
that I want the intersects with both
what is it yeah three nine zero seven so
this is sorry excuse me this is zero
point three nine zero seven okay
that's the whole answer right
I suppose I could say oh it's thirty
nine point zero seven percent maybe the
same but I haven't asked you to give the
answer in decimal percentage it's all
fine just before we go on do a quick
sense check three nine oh seven does
that feel like it should be about right
it does right we know it's going to be
less than 0.5 we know it's most of the
way though like you can see it includes
the tallest part of the graph so that's
why it's got a lot of I mean you know
point it's close to point four so it's
or its list of the way towards point
five are you with me